our future president slash amazing
source of vitamin C Donald Trump
recently met with Barack Obama to go
over the transition of power and also to
ask what do presidents do
Kossuth the exact moment of it just
sinking in what he's got to do right
here and Obama think according to CNBC
aides on Trump team were surprised to
learn the entire West Wing staff will
leave with Obama which is a bummer
because Trump was really looking forward
to saying you're fired do a bunch of
housekeepers Trump was also reportedly
planning to split his time between
Washington DC Trump Tower and mar-a-lago
because he doesn't want this job you
guys he doesn't want to do it he just
didn't think it through
right he's like The Twilight Zone ending
for Trump where he gets his Faustian
bargain you mean I actually have to do
this he's a billionaire he's 70 years
old the next four to eight years are a
considerable chunk of the rest of his
life and he's gonna do it
I don't know how funny it is to some
people but seems like Donald doesn't
know what the presidency actually
entails he's like America's drunk friend
watching American Ninja Warrior saying
y'all could do that except let's not so
hard want to do that except now 60
million people are like okay then do
that
why don't you now
comedians is president electing some
helping hints to get started
what are some other presidential duties
he should know about arm rings presiding
over the government of the United States
yeah points judge Doug Benson I don't
know exactly how the custom works Chris
but I think around the holidays he has
to choose a turkey and grab its lady
giblets
Levine he's got a new trade agreements
with other countries he has to negotiate
the ceasefire and the Middle East is to
reduce the federal budget I'm just with
you Dottie Mike Pence will handle all
that